the economy is doing really well but is
it the end of the world are we all going
to die according to the media sort of
President Trump announces his fake
Newsies and everyone is a GOG plus the
worst form of art / not art that you
have ever seen it's really horrifying
we'll talk about a ben shapiro show
[Music]
indeed many things to talk about from
the president speaking at the March for
Life which is a good thing to the
president tweeting out absolute nonsense
about his own policies that makes no
sense which is a bad thing
lots of good Trump bad Trump today we
may have to break out the old theme a
little bit later on in the show but
first we want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Birch gold so even
though the economy is doing really well
right now even though the stock market
is doing really well right now there are
a lot of people who are looking to hedge
their bets which is why of course there
are currencies like Bitcoin that are
doing so well well the original Bitcoin
is gold right that was the hedge against
inflation was the hedge against market
uncertainty and it remains the real
hedge against market uncertainty and
market inflation and the government
jackman round with the currency that's
why you should have it was part of your
portfolio in precious metals not the
whole thing
you should certainly have some of your
money in stocks and some of your money
and I don't really believe in bonds
which we leave in the butt stocks but
you should also have some of your money
in actual precious metals because it's
just a safe haven that's where my
friends over at Birch gold a group come
in they've a long-standing track record
of continued success thousands of
satisfied clients countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact them now for a
free information kit on physical
precious metals they have a
comprehensive 16 page kit and it shows
how gold and silver can protect your
savings and how you can legally move
your IRA or 401k out of stocks and bonds
and into a precious metals IRA to get
that no-cost no-obligation cocom slash
pen that is birchgold.com slash try to
make sure you have all your questions
answered and you feel comfortable and
then when you do birch cool to the
people you need to talk to birchgold.com
slash man that lets them know that we
say ok so we were told that all human
life would be ended it would be like
deep impact except if crisis had not
been averted by the tax cut right the
tax cut was going to end all human life
on earth and that obviously has been
happening the latest evidence that
millions will die because of the Trump
tax cuts comes courtesy of Apple run by
Tim Cook hey lefty who said that they
would now pay one-time tax of 38 billion
dollars on their overseas cash holdings
and ramped up spending in the United
States as they seek to emphasize their
contributions to the American economy
after years of taking criticism for
outsourcing manufacturing to China why
because we changed our tax policy right
now we've changed our tax policy the
corporate tax rates or drop dramatically
which means that now Apple doesn't have
to outsource right all of its costs just
went down for doing business in the
United States they say they
invest thirty billion dollars in capital
spending in the u.s. over five years
that would create more than twenty
thousand jobs the total includes a new
campus which initially is going to house
technical support for customers they're
calling missus Apple HQ to and right now
there's an open competition among cities
around the United States to get the new
Apple headquarters it'll probably be in
Austin Texas if anybody thinks it's
gonna come to LA that's on their final
list is LA they'd be fools to put this
headquarters in La La's a for lack of a
better term a bleep whole country I live
here I get to say that
okay the total includes a new campus and
ten billion dollars toward data centers
across the country
it also will expand from 1 billion
dollars to 5 billion dollars a funded
established last year for investing in
advanced manufacturing in the United
States now one of the reasons that I
think that this is good that Apple is
announcing this is as I've been saying
for months there's a difference between
the government giving a company specific
give away to places like Apple and
making broad scale policy changes that
have a good impact on Apple it's useful
for companies to sound off publicly and
say here are the policies that benefit
my business so long as those policies
are not specifically geared toward
paying you off yeah that's not what this
policy was designed to do
Apple's thirty eight billion dollar tax
commitment this corning The Wall Street
Journal is the largest such sum
announced in response to the major
overhaul of the u.s. tax code president
Trump signed into law late last year
that law included an incentive for US
companies to bring home offshore
holdings with companies required to pay
a one-time tax of fifteen point five
percent on overseas profits held in cash
and other liquid assets instead of them
having to keep all of that money
overseas instead they get to now bring
that money home and invest it here in
the United States these tax changes are
very good obviously not the end of all
life on earth so the so Tim Cook who is
the the post Steve Jobs head of Apple
was asked about all this he said some of
this was planned already but some of it
wasn't and the Trump tax cuts had
something to do with it no there clearly
let me be clear there there are large
parts of this that a result of the tax
reform and there's large parts of this
that we would have done in any situation
so it sounds like president Trump's tax
bill has been a huge windfall for Apple
well we - there are two parts of tax
bill right there's a corporate piece in
an individual case I do believe the
corporate tax side will will result in
job creation
and a faster growing economy okay so
again all of the talk about how this is
the end of the economy everything was
gonna go terribly it's nonsense the
stock market is gained a thousand points
in the last eight days consumer
confidence is high as well it should be
again a confidence in the economy is
less based on the actual policy that the
economy is currently sustaining it is
more based on predictability in the
economy if you're if you want a business
right we've run a business here at daly
wire one of the things that makes it
very difficult to do business in the
state of California is you don't know
from day to day
what exactly the state legislature in
California is going to do that means
that we have to think twice before we
hire someone do we want to hire somebody
simply to fire them I do want to hire
somebody simply to have our profit
margins cut arbitrarily by the state
through tax regulation do we the same
thing holds true in all areas of the
marketplace the marketplace is always in
flux that is why one I think it's George
Gilder who talks about the idea that the
economy a well-run economy should
basically be like the static on a phone
line right that the the job of the
government is to make sure that that
static is as low as possible there's a
certain predictability to whatever hum
is in the background the worst thing
that can happen on a phone is not that
they're static the dinners intermittent
static you actually would prefer a low
level of consistent static on a phone
call to every so often you just lose the
call for five to ten seconds because
then you can't understand what anybody
is saying it's the predictability of the
economy that matters even more than the
level of static in the economy so long
as the level of static in the economy
isn't it's some enormous rate where
nothing can get done and it totally
stagnates the economy now what's amazing
about all of this is again the economy
is doing really well
the jobless claims aren't their lowest
level now since something like 1973 so
there's still problems in the economy in
terms of people reintegrating into the
economy after years of spending time out
of the economy we're still paying too
much in terms of people who are on
unemployment insurance but the economy
continues to to do really well and the
Democrats are very upset about this
people on the Left are very upset about
this which goes to show you know when
people like me said we wanted Obama to
fail I said I think that rush limbaugh
was right I wanted Obama to fail the
reason I wanted Obama to fail was not
because I wanted something bad for the
country but because I thought I wanted
his policies to fail I didn't want him
as you know president to fail I would
prefer that he embraced all the policies
that I like do all those things in the
country succeeds the reason I wanted
Obama to fail is because he disagreed
with all of my policies and he helped
stagnate the economy the difference is
people on the left are actually not
happy when the economy does well right
when the economies did well under under
President Obama or did mediocre under
President Obama I urged caution because
I thought that his regulatory policy was
really bad but I was quite happy that
the economy was doing well you can see
the difference Chris Matthews is very
upset about this so he's back from
vacation you remember there are a lot of
accusations that Chris Matthews I don't
know that's how you stay and playing
hardball with female employees I've been
yelling at them saying mean things to
them wake in the morning those are they
show and say stop and that was back he's
on MSNBC with beardy McGee aired a lot
don't know who this guy is and and Chris
Matthews starts talking about how maybe
it is a bad thing if the economy grows
maybe it's bad for the merica if the
economy grows because Trump or something
I get this sense that one of the reasons
the Dow Jones is going up it's generally
good news but in this case I wonder if
it is because what it means is all the
stuff that we rooted for for the last 40
or 50 years the Clean Water Act the
Clean Air Act all the things that good
legislators like dead muskie got through
are being term itíd to death are being
killed by administrators who want the
government to fail in its mission that's
understand we need the regulations that
kill the economy cuz it makes life
better for so many Americans that's why
the regulation is great and if it screws
bunch of Americans and your stocks go
down you eat your 401 K well huh I laugh
at you and then I go buy another shoe to
cut my hair with first of all I love
that MSNBC actually has Chiron's like
this right look at the chyron on this
MSNBC clip I can just put up the
freeze-frame here it's even worse than
you think and then it just shows America
on fire yeah they're not rooting for
disaster or anything it's even worse
than you think with the maricón fire
well I didn't think it was that bad
honestly I think that it's a lot better
than you think I mean these people are
crazy people talk about Trump
derangement syndrome I mean this is
full-on from foreign German syndrome I
hope that the economy goes to hell so we
can blame Trump for regulatory policy
and it did this is comes from the same
school of thought where people are very
angry that in places like Seattle there
are companies that now will say here is
what your bottle of soda would cost here
is what it cost with the soda tax and
like doubles the price and they're very
angry that people would make this clear
or businesses that say here's what I'd
be charging if I didn't have to pay my
employees minimum wage bills l how dare
are they people did this with Obamacare
- okay reality suggests that when you
get rid of
regulations on businesses businesses do
better sorry that reality does but
that's just the reality but over on
MSNBC they refused to recognize reality
because reality is is oftentimes
discriminatory of sexist racist bigoted
etc okay so before we go any further
we're gonna get to Trump's fake news
Awards in just a second the fake Newsies
and they were shall we say
disappointment I was I was he should
have just Rick Rolled everybody it
would've been better but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
helix sleep so Hewitt sleep is the best
mattress on the market okay it's a
mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping style that
won't set you back thousands of dollars
it's great okay the reason I know it's
great is because I get so little sleep
but when I do sleep I better damn well
be comfortable and my daughter had a
horrible cough last night that means
that we didn't fall asleep till 1:00
a.m. but I'm here energetic and refresh
because my helix sleep at mattress okay
go to helix sleep calm slash man you
take their simple two to three minutes
sleep quiz they ask you if you like the
mattress firmer softer you like it to
retain heat or do you like it to
dissipate heat and they'll build a
custom mattress so that you and your
spouse can have different sides of the
mattress be at different settings and
it's the best thing you've ever slept on
we have she took more expensive mattress
and moved it out of our room in favor or
helix sleep mattress it comes to you in
the mail you open up the box and inflate
right there in front of you here enough
to slap on down to a store it doesn't
come in it you don't have to try and
figure out how to fit it through the
doorway and then you sleep on it it's
great and what's better is you can try
it for 100 nights and if you don't like
it they'll pick it up and refund you in
full go to helix sleep calm slash Ben
right now you get fifty dollars toward
your custom mattress that's helix sleep
calm slash Ben right now 50 bucks order
custom mattress it's a lot less
expensive than getting a mattress at a
retail store the markups insane helix
sleep you're getting really quality
stuff at a much from a less expensive
price helix sleep calm slash been for 50
bucks toward your order again that's
helix sleep calm slash Ben and use that
slash Bend so that they know that we
saying by the way they have other
products too like the helix mattress
protector the Machine machine washable
and dryer safe and completely waterproof
that's particularly good for ordering
for four kids so they have lots of great
products you look sleep calm slash menus
the /bounds they know that we sent you
okay so last night was the much-awaited
much-ballyhooed fake Newsies now I was
hoping okay if there's one thing that we
could expect from this president one
thing I think would be fair to expect
from this president it is that if you're
going to do a real
TV show at least be good at it I mean my
goodness The Apprentice is actually an
entertaining show from like the one
episode or half an episode I ever saw of
it before turning out but the but you
would expect it Trebek Trump has
actually appeared at the Tony Awards or
at the Emmy Awards and he actually did
an entire number of green acres with
Megan Mullaly I believe it was at the
Emmy Awards and you can find this tape
online of Trump singing Green Acres so I
was hoping for some musical interludes
from the president I wanted to hear him
sing Moon River I thought that'd be
great
and he can actually do it by mooning the
press during the fake Newsies Day Moon
River wider than a mile and then just
moon the press like yeah it could've
been fantastic it could've been great
all the way through none of that happen
instead it turned out that he's sort of
said that he was gonna give fake news
Awards and then he just half-assed it
another Moon River reference hey then he
just didn't really do it properly he say
tweeted out a link to the GOP comm
website and the GOP comm website was
basically like an article that you'd
find a daily wire or Washington Examiner
or the Federalist that listed like ten
of the worst fake news stories of the of
the of the year of 2017 he got some of
them wrong right he suggested for
example that CNN had edited remember we
talked about on the air CNN made a big
deal out of from dumping a bunch of fish
food in the koi pond and it turned out
that the the Prime Minister of Japan
Shinzo Abe a had actually done exactly
the same thing a minute before but you
didn't see that because the CNN camera
had zoomed in on Trump and then people
suggested that Trump was just a rude
buffoon because he did it himself so
that was on the list that they said that
Siena had edited the tape falsely that
wasn't really true there's plenty of
fake news on the list though I mean
again Chris Matthews suggesting that
it's even worse than you think his fake
news that of course is not true at all
but he releases
the fake Newsies and here are some of
the winners we'll go through some of the
winners what he said what first of all
CNN came in and in first place there the
Sally Field you like me you really like
me of the fake Newsies the New York
Times is Paul Krugman claims on the day
of president Trump's historic landslide
victory that the economy would never
recover first of all I love that the
that the Trump administration keeps
trotting out the lie that this is a
historic landslide victory it was not in
fact a historic landslide victory he
lost the popular vote by three mil and
just to be accurate it is fake news that
it was a historic landslide victory it
was not a historic landslide victory it
was a very very close election in
she lost the popular vote in the
electoral college he outpaced everyone
but I think George W Bush in 2000 he was
outpaced by every other election for the
past 40 years except for except for W in
2000 which was a dead heat essentially
then they put on ABC News's Brian Ross
choked and cent markets into the
downward spiral with false report that
is indeed fake news the CNN reporting
that Donald Trump in his son had access
to hacked document from WikiLeaks that
was fake news he's correct time
reporting the Trump removed a bust of
MLK from The Oval Office it wasn't
really time it was a time reporter who
tweeted it out then retracted it within
a couple of hours just to be a little
accurate here Washington Post reporting
but the president sold-out rally in
Pensacola was empty okay that should not
make the top ten that's just it's week T
okay it's like when crash won the Oscar
for Best Picture
that one really is not on the list but
beyond that it wasn't the Washington
Post that reported it again it was in
Washington Post reporter who then walked
that back with him I think in an hour of
tweeting it out and then I mentioned the
CNN video about the the feeding of the
fish
a CNN falsely reporting about Anthony
Skinner mood she's meeting with the
Russian and then retracting it due to a
significant breakdown in process that
was indeed a bad one
Newsweek reporting the Polish first lady
a gotta kornhauser Duda did not shake
president Trump's hand I remember when
the media did this I believe it was
again a reporter for Newsweek not
necessarily the publication itself
although Newsweek is a garbage
publication I mean today Newsweek has an
article about how Hillary Clinton could
still be president I am not kidding you
and not that she's gonna win in 2020
like how she can still be president now
how if they find collusion Hillary can
still end up president what's their
weird theory over at Newsweek
I'm not joking about this is an actual
thing their theory is that Trump would
be forced to resign and then pence would
be forced to resign and then Paul Ryan
would assume the presidency and named as
his vice president Hillary Clinton and
then Paul Ryan would resign that's the
actual argument Newsweek is making okay
by that standard I could be president
except that I'm not 35 right your dog
could be president by that standard Paul
Ryan could could grab gene Simmons the
frontman from kiss and make him
president by that standard and then this
is but when let me talk about the media
being insane and then Trump saying fake
news a lot this is why Trump says fake
news a lot is because there is indeed a
lot of fake news and also because let's
be real about the narrative here the
fake news narrative arose originally
because the media needed an explanation
for why Hillary Clinton had lost and
because they felt that they had not been
successful in elevating her to the
president
so if the media felt they've been
overcome what couldn't overcome them
well couldn't have been that people just
didn't believe them
it couldn't believe that it couldn't
been that people didn't believe their
narrative it had to be that there was
some nefarious fake news out there that
people were paying attention to now
there's a difference between narratives
that are false or legit fake news like
pizza gate and then stuff that the media
believe is fake news like people talking
about uranium one can uranium one is
actually questionable it's actually
questionable like there's a guy who's
indicted the other day for stuff that
had to do with uranium moines so the
idea that that everything in the media
disagree with on a narrative level is
fake news it is mirrored now by the
Trump administration saying everything
they disagree with on a narrative level
is fake news and then let's see what
else is on the list CNN reporting that
former FBI director Comey would dispute
Trump's claim he was told he's not under
investigation
the New York Times falsely claiming on
the front page that the Trump
administration hidden climate report
that was indeed a bad moment for the New
York Times so the newer Times got two of
these of these ten the CNN got four so
CNN definitely I mean it's like gone
with the wind they swept the Oscars they
swept the fake Newsies and then finally
everyone Russia collusion you knew they
were gonna have to put this on the list
last but not least Russia collusion
Russian collusion is perhaps the
greatest hoax perpetrated on the
American people
there is no collusion all caps okay I
agree that there's not a lot of evidence
of collusion at this point to say it's
perhaps the greatest hoax perpetrated on
the American people in history when
you'd probably have to put like the Gulf
of Tonkin Resolution up there maybe and
I mean if you're on the Left you'd have
to say the argument on weapons of mass
destruction in the Iraq war Russian
collusion and I'm not sure that that how
about the lie that blacks weren't people
for like a hundred and fifty years now
that I think that probably a pretty big
hoax how about the hoax that's it
currently existing since the 1960s the
babies in the womb aren't babies
they're instead magical kill creatures
that you can just get rid of with no
moral consequence but that is what it is
so what's hilarious about this is that
this comes out and everybody is really
celebrity for just a second like we're
all really excited maybe it's actually
to be a tape of Trump in a tuxedo with a
glass of champagne announcing the fake
Newsies it would've been amazing
you're an amazing I mean the troll
possibilities would've been incredible
and if you're not gonna troll well then
as I say you might have gone with the
pure rickroll I should have actually
just sent people to
actual video of Rick Astley singing
never gonna give you up which would've
been also amazing but instead we sorted
out the second-rate Oscars I mean it's
like it's like those years when they
they weren't using Billy Crystal and
they also weren't using Johnny Carson
and so they just had like this bunch of
randos in the middle there's a bunch of
people who you never heard of hosting
the Oscars and it was really like why am
i watching this that was kind of what
the fake news he's turned out to be but
what's hilarious about this is that
there's this image that's being
promulgate by the left and this one is I
would say if not fake news fake
narrative that Trump is the most
dangerous president ever that he's
SuperDuper dangerous he's dangerous to
press freedoms and this being helped
along by people like Jeff like the
senator from Arizona I agree with a lot
of flex critiques of Trump's language on
the press but the idea that Trump is a
legitimate danger to the press the guy's
not a legitimate danger to I mean the
only thing he's a legitimate danger to
is a Big Mac I mean the President of the
United States is not capable of taking
down the press I mean if the last look
at MSNBC's ratings okay the idea that
President Trump is doing severe damage
to the institution of the press he's
prosecuted fewer people in the press by
a longshot than the Obama administration
did he's been far more transparent
nationally with the press than the Obama
administration was this is not to
compliment his handling of the press I
think it's really dumb three quarters of
the time but there's this idea that that
he's some crazy authoritarian who's
about to shut down the press now listen
his language was Bogart to the press it
does give impetus to people who feel
like he's not gonna call out anti press
activity in foreign countries that's an
actual danger to foreign press but in
the United States the idea that the New
York Times on the verge of shutting down
that they're the failing New York Times
because he says failing New York Times
is just a figment of their imagination
so Jeff Flake who wants to run for
president in 2020 a primary Trump and
then force everybody into this this
awkward primary situation flake gave a
speech yesterday on the floor of the
Senate now I'll be honest I kind of like
speeches on the floor of the Senate that
has to do with broad topics because this
is what the Senate is for nobody showed
up for it though and I mean you can see
all the empty seats behind him you like
no one cared except for the press which
made a huge deal out of it here is flake
talking about the authoritarian impulse
sir president it is a testament to the
condition of our democracy that our own
president uses words infamously spoken
by Joseph Stalin to describe his enemies
it bears noting that so fraught with
malice was a phrase enemy of the people
that even Nikita Khrushchev
bate it's use telling the Soviet
Communist Party that the phrase had been
introduced by Stalin for the purpose of
quote and nya lading such individuals
unquote who disagreed with the supreme
leader this alone should be the source
of great shame for us in this body
especially for those of us in the
president's party for they are shameful
repulsive statements this feedback loop
is disgraceful
mr. president okay so I agree with the
idea that a lot of what trump says on
these topics is really ridiculous but
the idea that the etherion the
authoritarian impulse is what's the
animating America that we've reached the
end of America that fascism is upon us
listen I am very much afraid of
tribalism I'm afraid that that is that
we are getting close order to that point
under under President Trump but the idea
that we are really threatened by the
fake Newsies you know the president is
not you got to make a choice Democrats
is the president ineffectual or is the
president a true danger to Western
civilization you can't have it both ways
and I think that as I've said since the
beginning there's a strong case to be
made that the President of the United
States
you ought to attribute to incompetence
rather than malice most of the stuff
that he does that you don't like because
that just seems more honest to me okay
so in just one second we are going to
talk about let's talk about this
immigration fallout for just a second so
the the latest from the hill is that the
president is being a bit effectual the
President of the United States you just
undermined everything that his own party
is doing so right now there's a big
debate happening over a government
funding so the government has to get
funded I believe by Friday or we enter a
government shutdown territory now I'm a
person who doesn't care about government
shutdowns
you're probably a person who doesn't
care about government shutdowns if you
think you care about government
shutdowns it's because you don't know
what a government shutdown is mandatory
government services continue you are
still going to get your Social Security
checks you're still going to be you're
still going to be but then the military
will continue to be funded now the the
military ops will continue the
government will stay open right this is
why when there was a big government
shutdown in 2013 the the Obama
administration had a manufacturer crisis
they did say they had to shut down open
air monuments right things where there
wasn't any guard there they just shut
them down to show you that if the
government isn't operating you can't
visit this rock in this park here so the
idea that government shutdowns and the
world is silly but everyone wants to
avoid it because it's a it's a press
manufactured crisis and politicians
believe it because they think
most important people on planet earth so
the way this is operating is that
Republicans are saying here's what we
want we want a short-term continuing
resolution it'll continue to fund the
government for 30 days it won't be a
brand new budget or anything and in
order to get this passed we are not
going to include anything with regard to
daca so we're not going to solve the the
issue of the dreamers we're not going to
say that they can stay we're not going
to renew their their quasi green cars
we're not going to do any of that that's
a separate negotiation we just want to
fund the government and in order to
sweeten the deal and get Democrats on
board we are going to sign into law a
six-year extension of the children's
health insurance program now the
children's health insurance program is a
federal program by which the federal
government basically subsidizes states
to take care of underaged minors who
don't have sufficient health insurance
it's basically an expansion in expansion
of Medicaid on the federal level I
actually have some problems with chip
not because I think the government
doesn't necessarily have a role here but
because I think the federal government
doesn't necessarily have a role here if
states are going to shoulder the burden
or local communities are going to
shoulder the burden of what to do with
children who are underinsured that makes
a lot more sense I'm a local list at
heart I don't know where the federal
government finds the authority in the
Constitution to spend billions upon
billions of dollars on any of these
social programs and that includes even
ones that I think are doing good things
like like chip for example but it's a
very popular program it's obviously
going to be remanded all of that
Republicans have been trying to reman
date it since October Democrats refused
to go along with it because they want
some strings attached so right now the
Republicans are proposing that we go
forward with this that we go forward
with this temporary funding this
continuing resolution no cuts as always
because as I've said many times on the
show
no one has an interest in cuts everyone
has an interest in spending the
Democrats are saying though they are not
going to vote for the continuing
resolution now there's some budget Hawks
on the Republican side saying listen we
want some cuts you want to do this
continuing resolution stuff we want cuts
this would be the house freedom caucus
we need something in return for
continued funding of the government and
so that is leaving Republicans a little
bit short of a majority and no Democrats
are jumping on board because they want
the government to shut down because they
think that Trump will be blamed for a
government shutdown the reality is that
it's a little more complex than that
Democrats could sign up for this
continuing resolution and fun chip but
they're not going to do that so the
Democrats are very frustrated by this
tactic even though this is the same
tactic they've been using for years
it's one of the reasons by the way I
oppose omnibus budgets and
omnibus packages because it basically
allows you to take a a a sweetmeat you
know put something good in a sandwich
that's a crap sandwich and then say if
you don't vote for this crap sandwich
you're voting against the children and
if you don't like this continuing
resolution you're voting against the
children this is why I don't like these
omnibus packages I do think that
everything should be voted on
individually and funded individually you
shouldn't be able to pass a bill that
isn't funded and everything that you
fund should be passed on an individual
level so we can determine whether it's
something that is good or something that
is bad that's an ideological level but
what the Republicans are trying to do at
this point is get past the government
shutdown in order to do that they're
using chip as a certain amount of
leverage against Democrats are saying
listen you don't vote for the continuing
resolution you're voting down your
opportunity can to continue the longest
extension of chip funding in American
history
so naturally the Democrats are really
peeved about all of this and they say
well you know you guys should just fund
chip separately why are you connecting
the the why you're connecting all of the
funding in the continuing resolution to
all of this all of this chip funding why
arms putting data in there the
Republicans on the contrary are saying
listen you want the chip funding let's
just pass continuing resolution we're
good to go
only one problem President Trump has a
Twitter account so president Trump
tweets out today quote chip should be
part of a long-term solution not a 30
day or short-term extension maybe he
doesn't understand how this works that's
the Democrat talking point but the
Democrats are saying that they want chip
to be part of a long-term budget deal
not part of the continuing resolution
because they're trying to extract
concessions from Trump and team so
Senator John Cornyn actually had to
tweet out at the president exactly what
they were doing trying to explain to him
via Twitter how this works and by the
way it is a hundred percent true that
the president is coached more by Twitter
and by Fox News than he is by people who
are inside the White House okay it is
100% true that the most powerful Steve
in America was never Steve ban and it
was always Steve Doocy
right Fox and Friends which is you know
I think a a good informative show
there's no question that the President
of the United States watches Fox and
Friends and then makes decisions I mean
you can see how he live tweets Fox and
Friends I mean he really does it a lot
now all of that said is this gonna make
a huge difference not really but it is
demonstrative of the fact that if you're
gonna pose Trump as some sort of
nefarious evil doctor evil figure he
doesn't know the hell's going on guys
I mean let's be real about this in
policy terms in the last
three weeks has done this three times
three he did it on immigration remember
he did this in the in the meeting with
Democrats he started saying the dianne
feinstein's idea of taking daca off the
table of solving daca and then doing
comprehensive immigration reform he said
yeah let's do that it's time to clean
tackle bill and then Kevin McCarthy had
a step and go uh mr. president no
different oh yeah that's a minute when I
said yes it meant no right so there was
that and then last week there's a FISA
Act renewal that was up when the
administration position is that FISA
should not be weakened and at least with
regard to surveillance a foreign subject
and then Trump tweeted out because he
was watching Judge Napolitano on Fox and
Friends that we should weaken FISA
sending the entire thing into disarray
and we have this in disarray and now
immigration is in disarray so Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader is
just utterly bewildered as to what Trump
wants at this point he says listen we
are happy to support an immigration deal
as soon as we find out what the hell
Trump is talking about because I mean
let's be what like I don't know yeah I'm
looking for something that President
Trump supports and he's not yet
indicated hmm what measure he's willing
to sign as soon as we figure out what he
is for then I would be convinced that we
were not just spinning our wheels going
to this issue on the floor but actually
dealing with a bill that has a chance to
become law and therefore solve the
problem so there's McConnell saying I
don't know okay that's not great I mean
it's not great for the policy of the
United States when the president's own
party is trying to is scratching their
head going with a majority in Congress
going well your guess is as good as mine
guys now is this a little bit of it a
little bit of push for McConnell yeah I
mean McConnell knows deep down that he
could pass out anything in trouble sign
it Trump hasn't exercised his veto I
think one time in his entire presidency
so the idea that that McConnell will
pass anything and then Trump will sign
it is silly I think what what
McConnell's trying to do politically
here is avoid blame if he gets a bad
deal and Trump signs it then Trump will
just blame him I'll say listen I just
signed the deal they brought to me I
wasn't a part of the negotiation and
McConnell's trying to throw it back on
Trump saying dude give me something to
work with here
and Trump is like I don't know no you're
on your own
so this it's been a lot of fun to watch
the president fighting with his own
party again this does give the lie to
the idea that Trump is some sort of mega
mega mega you
genius who's going to destroy the world
you know that's that's just not accurate
okay so in a second I want to talk about
my hypothesis with regard to President
Trump and porn stars oh yes if that's
not a sexy tease nothing is so you'll
have to check that out by going over to
daily wear and subscribing for $9.99 a
month you can buy a subscription to
daily wire and when you do you get not
only the rest of my show live get the
rest of mandrill clayvin still alive the
rest of michael Knowles's show lie to
get to be part of my mail back tomorrow
and have all of your life's questions
answered in the most mellifluous fashion
I mean it'll be beautiful to listen to
you'll just enjoy it from top tomato be
fantastic so you get all of that plus if
you can get the annual subscription for
$99 a year you get all of those
wonderful things all of those wonders
and glories and this the leftist here is
hot or cold mug it is currently filled
with Cory Booker's tears it has been
filled with those for the last couple of
days at least I'm and there'll be plenty
more where that came from because not
because you know even bad thing is
happening the Democrats just because
they can't stop crying it's really weird
but we will talk about all of that also
I just wanna listen later iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube all of the places
where you can listen to the podcast
please subscribe at all these places and
leave us a review which always helps us
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all right I'll get back to immigration a
little bit but first I want to talk
about the the me to movement and Trump
and porn stars and all sorts of good
stuff so let's start with let's start
with Trump important stars so as I
mentioned yesterday there's a 5,500 word
interview that's about to break from a
woman named what what is her name now
Daniels her name is stormy Daniels which
is always a great way to come up with a
porn name right just come up with a come
up with a weather condition followed by
a first name right is so so cloudy Ryan
write it over it over here to be over
overcast Bob and not the greatest porn
and that one that one probably I can get
higher but but in any case but in any
case the this porn star supposed to give
an interview in which she fully
describes the president in the boudoir
which I mean frankly this is the first
time Trump is ever not wanted as happen
when he back in the 1980s Trump used to
pose as a guy named John Miller he'd get
on the phone with reporters be like hey
guys this is John Miller they'd be like
is this title true it no no it's not I
just had sex with a supermodel Nick
really which super mouth that kind of
the Bruni she was amazed and they'd go
to Carla Bruni really I'm no idea this
guy is or what the hell he's talking
about
and then be like well Trump says that
he's the best sex anyone ever had right
John Miller says it I know this John
Miller guy sounds exactly like Trump but
you know he says that he's unbelievable
in bed Carla Bruni what do you say she's
like I don't know I thought so it's been
it's been great Trump literally used to
call up tabloids and brag about the
people he was dating and he wasn't
dating like 3/4 of them now he's paying
women to shut up so apparently in 2016
he paid stormy Daniels who's obviously
he was obviously into her because of her
hire in selecting conversational ability
she is a is a important important star
she has sex for money on camera so
obviously of high quality and the
president has a particular taste in
women overall and so she is supposed to
give a 5500 more to interview in which
she also describes I guess the 2011
interview they're now releasing in which
she describes the president's genitals
which is just the only person in America
excited about this is Marco Rubio to
find out whether his theories about
hands eyes were in fact correct um but
the but all of this is happening and no
one cares hey this is the funny thing no
one cares so I'm old enough like this
week was the 20th anniversary
bursaries of the Lewinsky scandal in
which the President of the United States
had a consensual affair with the 21 year
old intern and everyone went nuts I was
there I remember it everyone thought
what an immoral piece of garbage this
Bill Clinton is now have a President of
the United States who is supported by 80
percent of evangelical Christians and
has sex with porn stars well he is
married to another woman who he was
having sex with while he was married to
another woman who he was having sex with
while he was married to another woman I
can follow this inception like sex life
okay by the time you get to the original
level of the dream all that is that
you're an old man waiting in pain and
despair in any case the no one cares
right no one cares like you don't care I
don't care no one cares so here's why no
one cares okay here's my theory of
President Trump in economics there's
something called the efficient market
hypothesis the efficient market
hypothesis is a is a hypothesis that
suggests you cannot beat the stock
market so all of these people who tell
you that if your day trade and you find
the inefficiencies in the market you can
make millions right all these people are
selling programs to you online about
this is how you beat the market you
cannot beat the market this is the
efficient market hypothesis the reason
being there are literally millions of
people who spend their day analyzing
every bit of information that is coming
out from every single company and then
that is priced in right it's baked into
the cake it's baked into the cake and so
stock market shocks usually happen when
there's a change in government policy or
and there's a downturn in government
policy and new information is added to
the system that's why the market goes up
and down but the idea that you can beat
the market because you know the market
better than anybody else is just not
true the evidence for the efficient
market hypothesis is that if you take
the people who are the top hedge fund
managers at any given point if you take
the people who are the top stock pickers
at any given firm in one year by the
next year the chances are that they are
actually the lowest on the totem pole
right people there's the chances that
somebody remains the best stock picker
ten years in a row is almost nil people
tend to bounce around a lot so they'll
have one great year and if they're lucky
that great years where they spent the
most money and bought the most stock or
sold the most stock and then they'll
have five really crappy years because
there'll be regression to the mean and
this is true if you actually look at the
performance of studies suggestion is
you're better off investing in stock
indices than you are in stock picking
and that is traditional kind of common
knowledge in the stock community and an
investment community if you ask somebody
for investment advice this is typically
what they will say
one of the big one of the big firms like
Goldman Sachs they'll tell you taking
her money stick it in the stock market
leave it there
that's why Warren Buffett didn't lose a
lot of money in the stock market in
2007-2008 because he continued buying
stock right my stock plan just so the
folks know is that I buy a certain set
amount of stock every month rain or
shine
it does not matter I tend to buy a
higher risk stock there's like a basket
of higher risk stocks I tend to pick
because I can afford to lose some money
if I lose some money I'm 33 or now I'm
34 my birthday was this week so you can
so I can afford to lose a little bit
money and then make that money back but
what I do is I'm constantly buying stock
and I never sell stock right I just
never sell it because if you hold on to
it the good news is if the market goes
down I just bought really cheap and if
the market goes down I didn't sell
really cheap so my stock portfolio is
always going up so long as overall the
market is going up that's the basic idea
of the stock market in the efficient
market hypothesis there are a few
different versions there's the strong
efficient market hypothesis which
suggests legitimately you cannot beat
the market and then there is the semi
strong version of the efficient market
hypothesis which suggests that publicly
available information you can't beat the
market but insider information it could
be the market the strong efficient
market hypothesis says even insider
information is priced in because there
are people who are inside these
companies trading stock of these
companies so the information is going to
come out anyway that's actually the case
against having insider trading trading
laws they're a bunch of libertarians who
believe insider trading laws are
actually negative because they prevent
like if I know daily wire is going down
the tubes I'm going to sell my stock
that's a hint to everybody else that
they should sell their stock to yours if
I were prevented from using my knowledge
about daily wire then that would prevent
the market from knowing the knowledge
that's the case for insider trading
so there's strong the semi-strong the
weak the weak basically says that you
might be able to defeat the market on an
occasional basis but you're not gonna be
able to do it very often essentially
here's my theory about Trump here's what
I'm talking about this my theory about
Trump is a strong efficient market
hypothesis there is no information
none that changes your view of Trump
none zero
literally anything anything in the world
could happen that President Trump could
do or it could be said about him or
there could be a report about him and
nothing could change people's views of
the President of the United States
because it's all baked into the cake now
and this is actually his strength and
it's also his weakness right his
weakness is that is very hard to
convince people that you're somebody
that you're not
and everybody has a strong opinion on
you the strength is that when you're
when you're hit by pornstar was was paid
off to the tune 130 grand and twenty
sixty nobody goes yeah but he's already
baked in that was already information
that we already knew we already knew who
this guy was character is the efficient
market hypothesis we already know
Trump's character everybody already has
a judgement and evangelical Christians
are gonna say listen I know the guy's a
scumbag when it comes to his personal
sexual morality did I did I ever pretend
otherwise like we already knew that but
King David I mean come on King David was
just like that or that will say but
that's that's the worst version ran it's
the Jerry Falwell Jr version then
there's the secondary version which is
yeah I know the guy's been a douche bag
but at least he's trying to stop
abortion right I mean he's gonna speak
this week in good Trump news he's gonna
speak this week at the March for life or
he's gonna go to the Rose Garden and
give an address and then appear on the
big screens at them at the March for
Life hey the guy's defending my
priorities so even if he's sticking his
wing wing in places I wouldn't right
then
so what rights baked into the cake so
there's a whole after I issued this
efficient-market hypothesis theory
yesterday online there are a whole group
of people trying to debunk it Jonathan
last over at the Weekly Standard was
saying is there anything Trump can do
like for example what if he selected
some bad liberal judges and what I said
is no that's already priced in the
market all that will happen is his
supporters will say listen he wanted to
appoint a conservative but the
Republicans just are too they're too
weak need in their support for him he
had to find a way to compromise and move
to the middle so he can win reelection
right they'll make an excuse in other
words had what if Trump committed murder
right let's take his theory he shot
someone on Fifth Avenue most people in
his base would say I probably deserved
it right most people who don't like him
would say you know what resident Trump
spent 71 years on this earth not
shooting people
you think you just shoot somebody for no
legitimate reason at all that means valo
we all know who he is we all know who he
is is the efficient market iPod the
problem is that if this is true in
politics if my theory is correct that
there is a strong efficient market
hypothesis that applies to characters
like Trump but doesn't apply to cleaner
characters it's a serious problem for
our politics if you cannot change or a
view of a man based on new evidence if
your judgment of his character is so set
in stone that nothing can change it
right if I'm the site of people like me
who think that he's deficient in
character if Trump made an open
confession of all of his sins and
decided to turn over a new leaf and
started talking
like a statesman could I change his in
my position on his character if the
answer is no then I'm so set in my ways
to problem the problem is this let's say
somebody good Mitt Romney runs for
president the strong efficient market
hypothesis no longer holds right any
piece of information about him will
change people's minds because he's seen
as clean the cleaner you are the less is
baked into the cake people do not give
good people the benefit of the doubt
they give bad people the benefit of the
doubt because they already knew they
were bad if you are good everyone wants
to see it come down a peg so if you're
Mitt Romney and you're basically you
know personally a saint I mean it's Mitt
Romney is about as good a person as run
for president of the United States and
then anything comes out about you
anything right you strap two dogs the
top of your car it's the end of the
world and suddenly it's a new piece of
information in the market and you start
pinging pawing around in the polls and
so there's something to be said for the
idea that Trump is stable not because
he's a stable genius but because
everybody has essentially made up their
mind about him and nothing is going to
change okay which brings us to the me to
the latest on me too so there's a tweet
that went out in the continuing collapse
of me too this is just another episode
Amber Tamblyn who's an actress
apparently a nice person from people who
know her she she was talking about this
case that was reported by babe we've
been talking about it for three days now
this insane piece reported by babe in
which a woman I had sex with his ease
I'm sorry or oral sex a couple of times
those ease I'm sorry
and then suggested that she had a bad
time and that this was somehow sexual
abuse or sexual assault she was ripped
by Ashleigh Banfield on CNN on HLN
here's Ashleigh Banfield going after
Ansari's accusers saying like listen you
got to have some standard for what
counts for sexual abuse here or we're
just talking about nothing and now here
is where I am going to claim victim you
have chiseled away at a movement that I
along with all of my sisters in the
workplace have been dreaming of for
decades a movement that has finally
changed an oversexed professional
environment that I too have struggled
through at times over the last thirty
years in broadcasting if you're lucky
there's a really good chance that you're
not going to experience the toxic work
environment that the rest of us have
endured and that is
because of the remarkable progress being
made against the Harvey Weinstein's and
the Kevin Spacey's of the world the me2
movement has righted a lot of wrongs and
it has made your career path much
smoother and here's where I'm guessing
it's gonna be a long career path you're
23 what a gift okay so she's talking
about the reporter who reported all of
this and she's saying listen you you
you're basically destroying the me2
movement and there's truth to this so
Amber Tamblyn tweeted out she actually
tweeted out I had dinner with a woman
who told me a brutal story about being
coerced into sex by a very famous guy
awful after seeing how the woman who
spoke about out spoke out about Ansari
is being treated she decided not to
share her story publicly let this lose
you some sleep tonight Twitter what
why'd you just come out and talk about
it like the problem here is not that
people are siding with rapists like
Harvey Weinstein or sexual abusers like
Kevin Spacey or any of these people the
problem is that this lady's story about
as he's on sorry did not wash right that
was the store that was the problem she
got naked in his apartment
praval intently performed oral sex on
him twice and then suggested that she
had given him no signals okay there's
another signal being given there but
again this is this this idea that all
stories have to be believed on the most
objective level it's the end of me too
and then here's the funniest thing so
Katie way is the name of this reporter
so Katie Way decided that she was going
to that she was going to respond to
Ashleigh Banfield and she was asked to
go on Ashleigh Banfield show here's the
letter she wrote which is just insipid
quote it's an unequivocal note from me
the way your colleague Ashley someone
I'm certain no one under the age of 45
has ever heard of by the way ripped into
my source directly was one of the lowest
most despicable things I've ever seen in
my entire life shame on her shame on HLN
Ashley could have talked to me she could
have talked to my editor my publication
but instead she targeted a 23 year olds
woman and one of the most vulnerable
vulnerable moments of her life someone
she's never effing met before for a
little attention
I hope the ratings were worth it I hope
the 500 retweets on the single news
write-up made that burgundy lipstick bad
highlights second wave feminists have
has been feel really relevant for a
while she disgusts me
and I hope when she has more distance
from the moment she has enough of a
conscience left to feel remotely ashamed
doubt it but still must be nice to
piggyback off of the fact that another
woman was brave enough to speak up and
add another dimension to the societal
conversation about sexual assault grace
wouldn't know how that feels because she
never struck out into this alone because
she
the bravest person I've ever met really
and then you should meet a soldier I
would never go on your network I would
never even watch your network no woman
my age would ever watch your network I
will remember this for the rest of my
career I'm 22 and so far not too shabby
actually a little shabby and I will
laugh the day you fold if you could let
Ashley know I said this that she's
no-holds-barred the reason it'd be a
real treat for me thanks Katie the
feminist movement doing itself all sorts
of favors by ripping other women who are
in favor of me - as burgundy lipstick
bad highlighted second way of feminist
has been well done Katie Way just
geniuses over there at the meeting
movement and then they wonder why people
are failing to take it particularly
seriously maybe it's because of all this
nonsense from the third wave of
feminists okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
in things I like my friend Jordan
Peterson who is really terrific
he was being interviewed on I believe
was CBC the Canadian Broadcasting
Company and he was asked by one by this
interviewer about why he does not use
the the gender the the gendered pronouns
that transgender people would appreciate
and this interview goes very very poorly
for the interviewer I mean this one is
like this one goes under Peterson
destroys on YouTube it's just hideous
here we go why should your rights to
freedom of speech Trump a trans person's
right not to be offended because in
order to be able to think you have to
risk being offensive I mean look at the
conversation we're having right now you
know like you're certainly willing to
risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's being rather uncomfortable
well I'm I'm very glad I put my you get
my point
there's like you're you're doing what
you should do which is digging a bit to
see what the hell's going on saying that
is what you should do but you're
exercising your freedom of speech to
certainly risk offending me and that's
fine I think more power to you as far as
I'm concerned you haven't sat there and
I'm just right I've just trying to work
that out I mean
ha gotcha ok so yes that is a bad moment
for because this is obviously true every
political conversation I've ever had
about these subjects as always why
should what you want to say Trump my
right to not hear you say it
like because that's the definition of
freedom of speech and we can't have a
conversation unless I'm actually telling
you what I think but this is it this is
how dumb the left is that they actually
think that I'm supposed to manufacture
what I believe in think in order to
please particular people which is the
opposite of an honest political
conversation ok time you know what we
can skip the thing that our production
crew spent so much time cutting and go
directly into things that I so here
let's do a couple of things that I hate
here so we begin with human nature I
hate it ok so that here's the thing
about human nature there is a story that
is out today from Daily Mail and it's
it's sort of hilarious so basically at
the time that in Hawaii people thought
they were going to be nuked into the
earth right then they thought they were
all going to die because a North Korean
nuclear missile the traffic on porn
sites dropped dramatically make sense
you only have half an hour to live you
probably have better things to do then
then spend it with one hand occupied
right you actually are going to are
going to hopefully make peace with your
God talk with your family you know watch
that watch that season finale of cheers
whatever it was that you were going to
do it's probably not gonna be spent on a
porn site here's the problem immediately
after the Alert ends immediately after
the alert ends porn sites it's a 50%
increase in traffic from Hawaii after
the ballistic missile threat was
revealed to be false right so in other
words in the shadow of death people like
well this is probably a bad idea to be
on this porn site right now like my wife
walks in right now my life is just gonna
end in a variety of terrible ways and
then as soon as it they're like you know
maybe I'll make peace with my god it's
time to repent it ends like okay I'm
back on on wackadoodle calm right I mean
this is just it's it's an astonishing
statement about what people feel when
they are under pressure and it's one of
the reasons why religion is necessary is
to remind you on a daily basis
you're gonna die okay I think that's a V
T dark about this but there will be a
time for you and at that time you might
think back on your life and think you
know if I spend hours a day in front of
a computer looking at images of women
who are acting for my benefit rather
than you know doing meaningful things
and that would be good but we have a
unique capacity as human beings to put
that out of our minds that we can waste
hours a day online looking at naked
people doing things to each other human
nature not the best place one of the
reasons why civilization is required
okay final thing that I hate so
everything is art now legitimately
everything is art now I've hated the
definition of art this way because if
art is everything that art is nothing
one of my favorite stories about this is
there was a modern art museum I believe
is in San Francisco where some guy went
into the modern art museum took off his
glasses put them on the floor and then
stood there and started taking pictures
of it and within minutes a crowd of
people had gathered around to take
pictures of this guy's glasses on the
floor because they thought that it was
an exhibit right because this is where
art has gone well the latest indicator
of art might be over we may be past the
days of Michelangelo and an art may be
dead like Rembrandt maybe maybe beyond
us they've now created a vibrator art
yes that's right now they have Mickey
they they have digitally charted female
orgasm and they have made art projects
out of this which is a really weird
thing to hang around your house I mean
like your kids are walking around you're
like mommy what's that well that was
September 11 2013 as greatest night of
my life like then just kind of weird and
so here is this idiot video like oh my
god I hope the world well I hope to god
that we don't get hit by a nuclear
missile and this is what I died talking
about because really that would just be
terrible this vibrator turns her orgasm
into art is what this video says the
women-led team at lioness created a new
vibrator with special sensors that
detect stimulation on the way to climax
and present it on a chart in the lioness
app and we never talked about sex
I wanted to create a vibrator that could
empower women to learn more about their
own bodies I like that people think they
invented orgasm like now like it hasn't
existed for the last several hundreds of
thousands of years orgasm in the West
did I miss that
okay the feature is available to app
users in the spring just just wonderful
stuff the I suppose that for men and
then the next the next invention will be
will be the will be fart art they'll
actually be able to chart your your
physical responses in real time to a
passing gas and that will now be
considered a high form of art again I'm
not sure this is any worse than Karen
Finley getting naked and smeared
chocolate on her body or people who have
done enema art which has been a thing in
art schools for literally years but it
doesn't demonstrate that we may be in
the decadent phase of capitalism we may
be in the decline and fall of the Roman
Empire here when we are literally
starting companies to sell vibrators so
that you can be solipsistic enough to
look at a digital imaging of your orgasm
my goodness
I wonder why society is on the ropes I
just can't understand it okay we'll be
back here tomorrow with much much more
hopefully much much less of that we'll
be back here with with more tomorrow
now I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018